the air is so insanely bad out here as
it's Indescribable apparently the DC
area was rated one of the lowest air
quality uh cities in the world and today
I wake up there is a white Haze so dense
it looks cloudy on a sunny day the the
the the light that's coming through the
windows is red and you can't breathe
it's even right now difficult to breathe
indoors we had to duct tape up the vents
to make sure air is not getting it from
the outside it's really really bad and
uh I came in the studio this morning to
record my morning show and uh I couldn't
talk literally couldn't do it I was
trying to just force air out of my lungs
and I'm just like I'm gonna go lock
myself indoors at home and then just try
and uh get my voice in shape to do the
show tonight and so uh here we are and
uh doing a bit better doing a bit better
but holy crap is it bad in fact it's so
bad we got a warning about our chickens
and had to transport them out of chicken
City